[تصفيق]
اليوم راح ابلش خطابي بكلمه السريانيه اي
كلمه بنسمعها معاني معقده
بس المعنى الابسط لها والاسهل هو لما يكون
في حالتين متناقضتين مع بعض ما بيشبهوا
بعض
يعني على سبيل المثال انا اليوم خطابي
اسمه صاحب النفس الطويل بينما انا شخص
وصاب بالربو من لما كنت صغير ما بتذكر انت
اخر مره
احد اوجه السيرياليه
تقريبا لما بدات طريقه تطوعي للاستجابه
لجائحه كورونا
هاتفي ساخن
وساعدهم بالاكسجين والرعايه الطبيه
فعلى سبيل المثال واحد اوجه السريانيه قصص
السريانيه اللي صارت معنا
مره كنا بمناسبه رسميه كان حفل تكريم
وكنا لابسين البدلات الرسميه وجرافيتات
احلى من هي
وبنهايه الحفل تقريبا اجاني اتصال من صديق
عزيز جدا عليه كان والده مصاب بالكورونا
وكان بحاجه اكسجين
فما كان في وقت لحتى نبدل فورا طلعنا
ننحفل اخذنا سياره نقل طلعنا على ظهرها
واخذنا اسطوانه اكسجين هي وزنها لا يقل عن
80 كيلو جرام
وتوجهنا لعنده لما وصلنا وصفينا السياره
شوي بعيده عن مدخل البناء نزلنا وحملنا
هاي الاسطوانه كنا ثلاث اشخاص
اسطواني ووديها على مدخل البناء وكان
صديقي ناطرني عند مدخل البناء فهو وقتها
هذا المشهد اللي شفته كتير سرياني بعد ما
فوتنا الاسطوانه قاعدين عم نتحدث قال لي
كثير سريعه وسالته شو يعني سريالي فجاوبني
بهذا المعنى انه 3 شباب لابسين بدلات
نازلين من ضهر سياره شحن حاملين اسطواني
وعم يمشوا فيها
هاي احد القصص السرياليه اللي مرقنا فيها
قصه تانيه كمان صارت بشهر ثمانيه 2020
كمان اجت مكالمه من سيده كان زوجها بحاله
صحيه سيئه جدا
وبحاجه اوكسجين بس هو ساكن بمنطقه بالجبل
يعني تسمى بالجادات منطقه كتير بعيده
والوصول لها جدا صعب
فهون اخذنا سياره اجره عموميه حطينا فيها
اسطوانه اكسجين وطلع طبيب معنا وتوجهنا
ونحن طالعين
البيت صاير باخر المنطقه يعني يعانق
السماء ونحن طالعين ما حسن فقد السيطره
السائق ما قدر يصف السياره فلحتى يوقف
السياره اضطر انه يصدمها بالرصيف
مشان بس توقف معه ونزلنا فورا حملنا
الاسطوانه فبناء على هاي الصدمه والحادث
اللي صار جمعت العالم وصارت تشوف شافو
طبيب ماسك الحقيبه الطبيه وعم يمشي
واسطوانه اكسجين وشباب حاملينا وبيعرفوا
انه في شخص عندهم بالمنطقه مريض فصاروا
يسفقوا ويصفروا وطلعت اهل المنطقه كلياتها
صاروا كلياتهم يصفقوا يصفقوا
رحنا لعند الشخص المصاب وطلعنا من عنده
والاهل المنطقه لساتهم متحمسين وكانه
كرنفالا ومهرجان
وانا كنت عاجز افهم تماما ليش بصراحه
ونحن نازلين صار نفس الموقف
السياره كمان السائقه فقد السيطره عليها
وصدم بسياره صافيه وكانت كتير حديثه
هون بتبين انه يعني جزء من المشكله على
السائق صراحه
يعني اول شيء حطيت ايدي على قلبي هاي
السياره حديثه وهلا رح نتغرم واكيد الحق
علينا
فصاحب السياره كان من الاشخاص المتجمهرين
فقرر انه لا انا شفتكن يعطيكم العافيه
وسامحنا ومشينا
بهاي المواقف وبهاي القصص انا دائما كنت
حابب احاول اعمل فصل الجانب العاطفي
والاحاسيس والمشاعر وحاول افهم الامور
بمنطقيه انه ليش الناس عم تعمل هيك شخص
على حافه الوفاه والعالم عم تصفق وتصفر
وكل البيوت اللي دخلتها دخلت عشرات
المنازل يمكن وقابلت عشرات الناس
في عالم شفتهم توفوا قدامي وفي عالم شفتهم
رجعوا للحياه قدامي
بس بكل هالقصص انا لما كنت تشوف هاي
الحالات يعني الشبه ميؤوس منها وما افهم
الناس يعني
هنا شو عم ينتظروا بعد الشفاء يعني احد
الاشخاص كان عمره فوق ال 75 سنه
نايم على فرشه موسوعه الاكسجين ما فيهم
ينفصل عن الاكسجين تماما وساكن بابو لا
يتجاوز مساحته 40 متر
رغم هيك هو يعني عنده اراده كبيره انه هو
بده يطيب
على اختلاف الاشخاص اللي شفتهم مختلفين
جدا
شخص كبير بالسن شباب صبايا دائما تشوف
عندهم
هاي الرغبه بالبقاء وانا يعني كشخص عم
حاول افهم انه شو الشيء الجميل جدا
الموجود بالدنيا واللي انا ما بعرفه اللي
بخلي كل هدول الناس حابين انه
يتغلبوا على هذا المرض شو الشي اللي بخلي
هدول الناس يكون عندهم نفس طويل بوقتهن
اساسا عاجزين ياخذوا نفس حقيقي فيه وبحاجه
اجهزه واسطوانات لحتى ياخذوا نفس حقيقي
في شاب كمان
كنا عم نحكي على شخص عجوز هلا رح نحكي عن
حالي مختلفه
شاب مصاب بمتلازمه داون
وكان ببيته وكنت ببيته قدام معنا طبيب
ووالده موجود وعم يصرخ من الالم وحاسس
ببرد بس يكرر انه انا بردان بردان وكل
المحاولات عم تفشل انه بس شاب يهدا بس
لحتى يحسن الطبيب يفحصه
فقال له ابوه
روق بابا بس الطيب راح اخذك مشوار قام هو
فعلا هدا جزئيا
فدائما هذا رجع نفس السؤال
شو المشوار اللي ممكن يخليه لهذا الشاب
انه انا ماني أدرون اتنفس كتير بردان عم
احس بالالم انا يمكن ماني قادران افهم ليش
عم تصير معي رغم هيك بضل عندهم هاي
الاراده
متل ما قلنا اذا شلنا المشاعر والعواطف
والاحاسيس وفكرنا بالموضوع بمنطقيه
انا بحثت عنه عنجد طلع في شي عند الانسان
اسمه غريزه البقاء
وغريزه البقاء هي السلوك اصيل عند الانسان
غير مكتسب اذا بنجيب عده افراد
من بيئات مختلفه وبنحط كل واحد بمكان
الاتنين حيكون عندهم غريزه بقاء اراده
الحياه هذا سلوك موجود هاد غير مكتسب
نرجع خطوه لوراء ونشوف نحن هلا مجتمعين
كلياتنا بهذا المكان شارع الامل
نفس الشيء لما سمعت عن شارع الامل اول شيء
عملت لحتى اعرف انا بس شو بدي اكتب عملت
بحث على كلمه الامل
بالمعجم شو معنى كلمه الامل طلع معي انه
معنى كلمه الامل هو تفاعل الانسان انه
يكون عمره طويل
وبحاله صحيه جيده وعنده عائله هي امور
كلياتها مرتبطه بالبقاء
الامل مترابط مع البقاء الانسان عنده رغبه
ونزعه بالاستمرار مهما كانت الظروف صعبه
وهي الرغبه موجوده فينا الرغبه بالاستسلام
والرغبه بالهزيمه والرغبه بالانسحاب هي
النزعات الدخيله بينما رغبتنا بالبقاء
ورغبتنا بالاستمرار هو السلوك اللي نحن
اجا معنا من لما اجينا على هذا المكان
رجعت
ودورت كمان انا بعد ما شفت معنى كلمه
الامل وصرت فكر شوي بكل شي صار معي
واكتشفت انه انا رغبت البقاء عندي
وهاي النزعه عززتها بثلاث عوامل حابب
شاركها اول عامل
هي الجماعه او انا بطلق عليها بحالتي
الشخصيه الرفاق
وانا تبين معي من التجربه انه الانسان
يكون عنده هاي الرغبه اقوى وقدرته على
الاستمرار اكبر لما يكون بيحاط بجماعه
ولما يكون منعزل هون بتطرق عليه النزعات
للاستسلام والانسحاب والهزيمه بغض النظر
عن اي سياق عم نحكي فيه بالحياه سواء كان
دراسي او عملي او عاطفي بس احنا ضمن
الجماعه بنكون اقوى لما نكون محاطين برفاق
او اصدقاء او عائله بنكون اقوى
لهيك انا ما كنت اسمح لاي شيء يتغلب على
ولائي لعائلتي والاشخاص اللي بعدهم من
عائلتي والاشخاص اللي بحبهم لانه كان هذول
جزء من وجودي هدول اللي عم يعطوني سبب
لحتى اكون متواجد لحتى تكون مستمر اذا
رجعنا على السرياليه نحن يمكن الحدث اللي
نحن موجودين فيه اليوم والشيء ونحاول
نعمله الرساله عم نحاول نوصلها هي سرياليه
ضمن الظروف الموجوده بالعالم الخارجي بس
رغبتنا بالبقاء وجودنا ضمن هاي الجماعه هو
عم يدفعنا انه نستمر
انا كنت محظوظ جدا انه انا كان عندي
اصدقاء بامن فيهم وبامنوا فيني
محظوظ جدا انه كان عندي عائله واصدقاء
بحبوني وبحبهم
لهيك ما قدرت اتخلى عنهم لانه بكل لحظه
انا بكون فيها لحالي
هاي الغريزه تبعي والاستمراريه بتنزل شوي
شوي يمكن كلياتنا ونواجه نفس الموقع لما
نكون بدنا ننام ومتسطحين على المخده هذا
الوقت اللي بتهجم علينا فيه الافكار
السلبيه هذا الوقت اللي بيطلع شعور الندم
وبنفكر لو صار ولو كان وليش انا عم بستمر
ليش انا بهذه الجامعه ليش انا عم بشتغل
هذا الوقت لما نكون لحالنا اضعف مواقفنا
لما نكون وحيدين
شي تاني
العامل الثاني اللي عزز عندي رغبتي
بالاستمرار وبالبقاء هي الاستمراريه هلا
انا شخص كتير بحب ادعيني بصراحه وبحب ادعي
انه انا يعني ازكى من المعدل الطبيعي
بس للاسف لازم اعترف بحقيقه انه انا ماني
هون اني انا ذكي وانا ما قدرت اعمل شي
لانه ذكائي كان
يعني فوق المتوقع لان ذكائي فوق المتوقعه
بس مو هذا السبب انه انا موجود هون
السبب انه انا موجود هون هو الاستمراريه
الاستمراريه بمجهود بسيط
بسيط مو يعني سهل بسيط يعني غير معقد
يعني كل شيء انا كان لازم اعمله انه انا
لازم في كل يوم الصبح وروح ادي هي المهمه
انا ما كنت بحاجه حلول سحريه ولا ذكيه ولا
عبقريه ولا من خارج الصندوق خارج الصندوق
شيء كثير حلو وكلياتنا بنحب يكون عنا حلول
من خارج الصندوق بس لما نعجز انه نلاقيها
ليش لحتى ما ندور بهذا الصندوق
الذهب للجامعه التعلم عن بعد في كتير حلول
داخل هذا الصندوق وموجوده قدامنا ومتاحه
بتصير بتعمل فرق كبير لما بنعملها بشكل
مستمر يوم ورا يوم حتى بالايام اللي ما
بنكون محفزين فيها حتى بالايام اللي ما
بيكون عنا في طاقه او شغف او حب للحياه او
اي مصطلح من المصطلحات الرائجه
بغض النظر اذا موجوده او غير موجوده
مجهود بسيط متكرر بيعمل الفرق
بموضوع الكورونا كان المجهود البسيط اللي
الناس بحاجه تعمله
تمام في ابسط من اللبس كمامه
لما صارت كورونا وكنا نحنا مفكرين انه هاي
الجائحه رح تستمر وقد تقضي على نصف
البشريه فالناس كانت عم تنتظر حلول من
خارج الصندوق
بينما الحل كان بسيط نعمل لقاح من فيروس
ميت او من الحمض النووي تبعه وبس لازم
نعمله بشكل مستمر انه كل يوم نلقح عدد
كبير من الناس كل يوم نوصل لعالم اكثر ما
كنا بحاجه دواء سحري ما كان في اكسير
للكورونا الكورونا انتهت او شبه انتهت
بسبب انه عملنا هذا المجهود البسيط بشكل
مستمر
ونحن طبنا من هذا المرض انه نحن عملنا هذا
المجهود البسيط انه لبسنا كمامه
وكنا محظوظين
فالاستمراريه كانت العامل الثاني اللي
خلاني
اكون موجود قدامكم اليوم وتشوفوني انا
ماني قادر اشوف شي بس انتم عم تشوفوني
[تصفيق]
العامل الثالث
العامل الثالث هو التسليم
وهو مرتبط بالاستمراريه تسليم تسليم انه
نحن رح نعمل المطلوب منا بغض النظر عن
النتائج
لانه الامور ممكن تكون سيئه ممكن تكون
اسوا من اي وقت مضى باي صياق لكن التسليم
تبعنا انه نحن رح نضل عم نستمر بفعل رح
نضل نروح على جامعاتنا رح نضل عم ندرس رح
نحاول نشتغل ممكن جماعه النادي انا كتير
بعيد عنكم بس بقدر المجهود اللي عم تعملوه
كل يوم وبحترمه
تسليم مرتبط بالاستمراريه انه انا ممكن
ممكن ما وصلنا نتيجه
بس بفصل انا ما عم بعمل هيك لانه هون
بنرجع نحن ما عم نعمل هيك نحن ما عم نبذل
هالمجهودات اليوميه البسيطه لانه احنا
ناطرين نتيجه نحن عم نعملها لسبب تاني
نحنا بشر ولا انسان ولاني انسان فانا عندي
هاي النزعه بالبقاء
شو ما صار على هذا الكوكب الصغير من امراض
او بيئه ومشاكل وحروب انا نزعتي للبقاء رح
تتفوق
في حيله نفسيه لطيفه انا بحب استعملها مع
حالي
لما تكون الامور سيئه استعملتها كتير
باوقات الكورونا
انه انا بتخيل حالي بعد عشرين سنه
وبتخيل انه انا قاعد محاط باشخاص عائلتي
وبتخيلهم عم يسالوني انه مثلا بابا بابا
من عشرين سنه لما صار عندكم كورونا انت شو
عملت
فانا
او مثلا اللي بابا بابا لما كان عندكم حرب
كيف كنت تروح على الجامعه
قصه عظيمه
التفكير بالمستقبل البعيد والبعيد كتير
كان يعطيني شويه حافز احد الحيل النفسيه
اللي انا بستعملها مع نفسي وحابب شاركها
معكم
بالنهايه
الشي الي حابب اوصل له يمكن نحن كل الامور
هاي اللي عم نحكي فيها مرتبطه بالوقت
الامل اللي هو تفاعل الانسان انه يطول
عمره
والاستمراريه تبعنا وحتى السرياليه اللي
بلشنا فيها هي دائما كل شي بتغير مع الوقت
ونحن نزعه البقاء تبعنا انه نحن نضل
مستمرين لاطول فتره ممكنه
وهذا الشيء بيعمل ولاء لكل مجهوداتنا
بالماضي وللعالم اللي كانت من قبلنا
ولما يكون عنا هذا الولاء نحن لازم ننقل
هاي الشعله للاشخاص من بعدنا
ومثل هلا رح ابين انا انه انا شخص كتير
قايم كلمه بتواجهني بروح بدور عليها بس
انا عن جد رح دورت على الوقت كمان مثل ما
دورت على الامل
ولما دورت على الوقت واسترجعت يعني اتذكره
من دراستي
انه شو هو الوقت اكتشفت انه يعني هو الوقت
في النظريه النسبيه الى اخره بس في حقيقه
وحيده مطلقه عن الوقت انه مهما كان الزمن
صعب مهما كانت الظروف صعبه الشيء الوحيد
اللي بنعرفه عن الوقت
انه بيمرق
وهذا الوقت رح يمرق لهذا السبب انا قررت
تكون صاحب نفس طويل شكرا
[تصفيق]